what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and in yesterday's video we talked about
how Marvel was starting to make some
pretty big changes in the MCU we talked
about Marvel Studios making more mature
type content and it sounds like
Spider-Man is going to be no exception
to that and I believe that a lot of fans
are going to think that what we're about
to talk about in this video is some
pretty great news as far as Spider-Man
in the MCU goes we have a lot of plot
details to go over about the film Plus
have a report of who Marvel Studios
wants to direct Spider-Man 4 and a lot
of people might be really excited about
this and if Marvel Studios gets their
choice it could be a big change in how
we see Spider-Man on screen so a lot to
dive into let's get to it but if you're
new be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU videos and if
you subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items the
winner picks one item we pick one winner
at the end of every single month so
we'll go over who Marvel Studios is
eyeing for their director for Spider-Man
4 because once we talk about that then
the rest will make a lot of sense and
make you even more excited about the
plot details like Daredevil being a part
of Spider-Man 4 according to The Insider
Daniel rpk Marvel is eyeing Drew Goddard
as the Director of Spider-Man 4 so we've
heard rumors in the past that they
perhaps want John Watts to return but as
more time goes on it doesn't seem like
Marvel Studios is looking to do that
John Watts directed the first Spider-Man
home coming Trilogy and whether or not
you really liked the Spider-Man trilogy
there's no doubt that it was a massive
success box office- wise each movie
performed extremely well and I still to
this day love Spider-Man no way home but
one thing that fans really kind of had a
problem with is that Spider-Man kind of
had his handheld the entire Trilogy he
basically had a babysitter the entire
time in homecoming and of course in
Civil War as well it was Tony Stark in
far from home it was Nick Fury and happy
although Nick Fury was really taor then
of course in Spider-Man no way home the
other two Spider-Man popped up which
again I loved I'm not complaining about
that at all but what Spider-Man no way
home did at the end was set up
Spider-Man to finally be on his own then
we started hearing reports that there
are going to be other characters coming
into Spider-Man no way home like
Daredevil and possibly Ant-Man to maybe
be the mentor the new mentor to Peter
Parker which a lot of people didn't like
because a lot of people want him to be
on his own well as we find out a little
bit more about the plot of dare devil
born again and Spider-Man 4 we are
figuring out that that might not
necessarily be the case Spider-Man might
not be getting a mentor but he might be
getting more along the lines of
colleagues which is fine we're also
learning that Spider-Man isn't exactly
going to be a part of the Avengers team
in the next Avengers film he is going to
be in the movie but might not be a part
of the actual official lineup and we'll
tell you why in this video Spider-Man is
going to be a part of several projects
in the MCU that connect to each other
other the big one that Spider-Man will
connect to is Daredevil Born Again born
again is going to set up a lot of the
plot for Spider-Man 4 and here's the
really cool thing Drew Goddard was
actually the one who developed the
Netflix Daredevil series he was the one
who developed it in the beginning and
then he left to work on a Sinister 6
movie for Sony which never got made but
he was already being eye to direct
Spider-Man related projects so this
would be a perfect fit for him him to
direct a Spider-Man movie that is
directly connected Ed to Daredevil and
we probably have Daredevil in the film
so let me explain how everything is
going to connect and how Spider-Man 4
could be a pretty dark movie we could
see a very darker version of Spider-Man
and how that Civil War Rumor for
Spider-Man 4 could be true you see a big
part of what is going to happen in
Daredevil born again is that Wilson Fisk
AKA Kingpin is going to become the mayor
of New York and from what we've heard he
does try to be good but he wants to make
the galanes illegal this makes Matt
Murdoch very busy as a lawyer and this
could be how he gets brought into
Spider-Man 4 Spider-Man of course is a
vigilante now luckily for Spider-Man not
sure if this was intentional or just a
very good coincidence but luckily for
him the memory of Peter Parker has been
erased from everybody so nobody knows
who Spider-Man is so he can go about
being Spider-Man and not have to worry
about cops knowing who he is and showing
up to his door going hey Peter Parker
let's go you're going to jail because
you're a vigilante but kind of like we
know Spider-Man to be he is going to be
a vigilante and the cops are kind of
going to be against him SL for him
sometimes and based off of where we left
from no way home he really is kind of
going to be on his own Matt Murdoch AKA
Daredevil will come in because
Spider-Man might actually seek legal
counsel for this or it could be the
opposite Daredevil could actually seek
out Spider-Man because like I mentioned
from what we've heard there is going to
be somewhat of a Civil War Story going
on in Spider-Man 4 it's previously been
reported that Ant-Man could show up as
well and people know know who Scott Lang
is people know that Scott Lang is
Ant-Man so he could show up in a city
where being a vigilante is illegal and
get mixed up kind of in a war that is
not his but what we are assuming is
going to happen is that there are going
to be heroes all around who have
different opinions on what they believe
is right or wrong basically like Captain
America Civil War some believe the sovia
Accords were necessary and of course
some thought they weren't same thing
that goes for Wilson Fisk making
Vigilantes illegal I'm assuming
Spider-Man is going to not care about
that I'm assuming Daredevil is probably
not going to care about that but might
be a little twisted in his opinion
because after all he is a lawyer
representing a lot of people but at the
same time he knows Kingpin is behind
this and he knows how bad Kingpin is if
you didn't catch my video yesterday
Marvel Studios confirmed the Daredevil
Netflix series is Canon to the MCU
sacred timeline so everything from the
Netflix Daredevil series happened in the
MCU they are including that as a part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe which is
awesome and again Drew GD developed that
Series so him to come in to direct
Spider-Man 4 would be great and like I
mentioned the overall tone would be much
darker like Daredevil Vinnie denafo who
plays Kingpin in the Netflix series and
of course in the MCU now even stated
recently that his character being
introduced in echko under the Marvel
Spotlight Banner TV mature rating was a
really good thing because his character
needed to be viewed in a mature type of
manner like he was in the Netflix series
the same thing I think goes for
Daredevil in fact Vinnie afio said that
he expects Daredevil to be under that
Marvel Spotlight Banner as well and for
the project to be TV mature so
Spider-Man 4 is going to pick up pretty
much where Daredevil leaves off then if
we have drew GD directing Spider-Man 4
we can definitely expect a more mature
tone for Spider-Man which I think a lot
of people really wouldn't mind and don't
get me wrong we don't want him to lose
his charm or his personality but giving
the situation that he's in right now it
is pretty rough for him he doesn't have
Tony Stark he doesn't have on May happy
doesn't know who he is nobody knows who
he is literally he has nobody so it is a
pretty dark and rough time for him he
doesn't even have MJ or Ned so what has
been set up is naturally a darker tone
for the next Spider-Man films and going
back to the Civil War plot for
Spider-Man 4 this could be why he's not
a part of the official lineup for
Avengers 5 another project that will tie
into Spider-Man 4 a little bit is
Captain America Brave New World in
Captain America 4 we're going to find
out that the president of the United
States was actually Red Hulk and we're
assuming Captain America is going to
take him down and the world's going to
see this so they might start to question
again if superheroes are good or bad for
the population we're essentially kind of
going through phase three again of the
MCU we're in a different place now the
sovia Accords have been taken away they
don't exist anymore because of course
the Avengers saved the universe from
Thanos and Avengers endgame but it seems
like people are easy to forget what
happened and now it's kind of going back
to well are these superheroes doing good
or are they actually harming the city
and now the president is a Hulk and
that's super concerning in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if this linked
with Daredevil born again and this was
one of the reasons that Kingpin or mayor
Wilson Fisk decides to put an outlaw on
vigilantism and Sam Wilson could show up
in Spider-Man 4 as well and could be
against Spider-Man he could be for him
he could be against him but either way
he might be a part of the Civil War and
Spider-Man might decide to go against
him which is why he might not be a part
of the official Avengers roster because
Captain America Sam Wilson's Captain
America probably thinks that he can't
trust Spider-Man especially if he
doesn't know who he is and we have heard
reports that Spider-Man 4 is going to
focus more on Spider-Man and not Peter
Parker which again if you think about
all of the circumstances that have been
set up by the previous movies and the
upcoming projects this makes a lot of
sense nobody knows who Spider-Man is
however the Avengers the remaining
Avengers who know who Spider-Man is is
are going to have to deal with the fact
that they don't actually know his
identity because remember the doctor
strange spell made it to where people
forgot who Peter Parker was not who
Spider-Man was everybody still knows who
Spider-Man is so the Avengers should all
remember fighting alongside Spider-Man
and Avengers ingame however they don't
know that he's Peter Parker and since
they basically know the identity of all
of the other superheroes it might kind
of rub them the wrong way that they
don't know who Spider-Man is and if
Peter Parker doesn't want to reveal his
identity then there might be some kind
of distrust there distrust that would
make Sam Wilson go well maybe he can't
be a part of the Avengers right now
because I don't trust him now again
going back to what I said before just
because he might not be a part of the
official lineup at first doesn't mean
he's not going to be a part of Avengers
5 in fact we've heard that he is going
to be the lead character of Avengers 5
and of Secret Wars so don't sweat about
that he's still going to play a huge
part in the future of the MCU and the
future Avengers films but let me know
what you think about Drew Goddard
possibly directing Spider-Man 4 and
Spider-Man 4 5 and six possibly having a
darker tone than the Spider-Man
homecoming Trilogy do you like this do
you not like this let us know all of
your thoughts in the comments down below
please don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest Spider-Man and MCU
news you can find us on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof
woof